my name is Thomas fan and I'm presenting
you scorch a union of scikit-learn and
pythor how many of you have heard of
scikit-learn
yeah all of you looks like cycle urn
provides interface to Python along its
try to unified interface to define your
machine learning algorithms so in this
case you could define a category in the
same classifier if you want to train it
you call fit if you want to predict from
it predict some algorithms allow you to
do online training where you continue
training your algorithm which you call
partial fit and specifically to cycle
learn you could change hi parameters of
your classifier by calling set params
alright very standard self how many of
you have heard of pi torch all right I
could skip through a lot of things this
pi torch if you want to train a neural
nets you could easily write for loops to
train a neural net but normally you want
to do more than that you want to record
metrics so you write some more code to
do that but you know back in
kindergarten we learned that we have to
split our training our training data
into training of validation sets so we
do that as well and this a lot more
stuff we have to do we have to do
calculate validation losses do some sort
of saving of our motto record our
metrics logging etc etc so these piece
of code you share between your deep
learning experiments and if you have
you'll have to rewrite them over and
over again scorch provides a way to
unify what you do it's a cycle learning
compatible neural network library that
wrapped pi torch it objects the way or
the code we just saw so you don't have
to think about the training loop or the
evaluation loop and whoever who here is
familiar
Kiera's clearance right here so taken
inspiration from Kira's scorch also uses
callbacks to reduce boilerplate code
okay the big object in scorch is the
neural net object which is from which is
you can import it from a top-level
module it takes a module which is how
high torch defines a neural net to train
on o-net you also need a loss function
which you define using that criteria
parameter and it takes in a list of
callbacks rather than going through the
API and just spoon you what the Scourge
API is I thought be fun to go through
some example data sets and show you how
we could use scorch to solve these
problems
so first to emili´s data set pretty
simple
next ants versus beast classifier which
we will use chance for learning and
lastly the 2018 cago data science Bowl
which is an image segmentation problem
okay I'm gonna say that said everyone
everyone knows I'm the state aside 28 by
28 grade scale labels between 0 & 9
there's so many thousand of them if you
flatten the 28 by 28
you get 784 ok simple remember
kindergarten we have to do our training
test split to split our training set and
train the data into training and test
sets notice in this case I manually
skilled my data set by dividing by the
maximum value so now our data x values
are between 0 & 1 for this example we're
going to create a simple module a
feed-forward neural net it takes in a
input of size 780 form goes through some
nonlinear functions spits out array of
98 goes to another function and at the
end it spits out a vector size 10 for
those who don't know to define this
module you have two sub class the module
class from PI torch remember to call
super in it and you're in it Thunder in
this function and define a forward
method then you can write this module
this diagramming code notice that my
inept underneath method has a drop out
parameter okay it's equal to 0.5 I'll
come back to this in a moment
next to train on o-net we need a loss
function to optimize one common way to
define a loss function is as follows
there are no Nets will output a vector
of size 10 which could be any real
number so in this case in this example
just this vector if you want the
probability take the softmax and if you
want a loss function you take the
negative log of it and pi torch there's
something simple the cross sign should
be lost
okay now so you have the module and
criteria so you place that into the
neural net object and Scorch and
criteria and there's three more
parameters we have should set the max
epoch is how many times you want to run
through your training set and the
learning rate which is a hyper parameter
to the algorithm to optimize the loss
function lastly you need a device and
you could if you want to run it on a GPU
you set the device parameter to CUDA if
you want to run on CPU you could comment
it out and run our CPU so the moment of
truth next we could just call fit on
this no net and object and no fit your
neural Nets like so notice that it
outputs training laws
validation laws and the duration of each
epoch we didn't really split the
training set into your validation set it
doesn't scorch does it by default
splitting our training set and this
gives extra on the score train into 80
percent training and eight twenty
percent validation remember that
scikit-learn
you has a set params method and if tips
in this case if you want to continue
training this no net let's say this is
not good enough for only five be parts
we could do that we could call set
params with the math epoch and go to
five and called partial fit design
partial fit continues training the
neural net and start remember before we
started at epoch ten now we start at 11
epoch 11 and then in 15 after training
we scorch has a special object called
history which stores all the data we
just saw before the length of the
history is how many parks we train there
no net it could also do indexing so in
this case negative one means that we
want the last item of the validation
lost column right that works we also do
Python slicing which is as follows you
have if you want the last two values you
juice negative two normal slicing simple
there's other metrics you could use in
this case let's say you want to do
accuracy score for accuracy score we
have to define a psychic Lorne score
who's familiar the score interface and
scikit-learn kind of all right it's very
easy to advanced I could learn in to
score interface you define your own
custom score metric in this case it
takes the true value the predictive
value
combine them to form the accuracy score
afterwards if you want to create the
score objects cycle learn provides a
mixed score up function that gives you
the score so simple now Scorch has a
callback our first callback called that
epoch scoring callback it takes in the
score we just created you have to name
it so it knows what to put on the blog
and importantly you have to set lower it
it's better to false because it had
higher accuracy score it's better next
we just stick it into our no net put it
in the list of callbacks and lots of
callbacks and call fit notice now we
have a new column
called the validation accuracy back as
we named it before and this is the
accuracy of the neural net model over
the epochs if you want to call predict
now you can call predict just excited
learn and it works and if you want
accuracy your core accuracy since
scourge the ports as I can learn API you
could use it with all the other cycle
scikit-learn API such as pipelines all
right so with pipelines we don't have to
do that scaling we did in the first and
the vorn of the first few slides we
could just use cycle learns min max
killer stick it into a pipeline and
throw a call fit and this would do all
the processing for you and it just works
as well next since scores also supports
except params and get params paradigm
and scikit-learn you can also grid
search over it
Chris searching with by calling grid
search CV you've also do random search
TV as well and if your who's familiar
with this API the grid search like yeah
this is you could do hyper crime
searching you use the double underscore
to denote which parameter you want to
change
remember our module had dropout
parameter in this case I want to vary my
drop up parameter but by 0.3 0.5 and
point 8 and we could do cross-validation
with the grid search API and everything
just works as well okay so the MS data
set that's very simple data set it fits
into memory usually we do deep learning
everything doesn't fit into memory right
so as an example I'm gonna use an image
images to train to Train unknown a
classifier to distinguish between these
beautiful images of ants they finance
beautiful and then love the images of
these ok
to to get the data out of this dataset
if you look when you download the data
you get the images into these folders
where the training and validation set is
already split up for you
so torch vision comes with this very
special object that forms
that's called an image folder which you
get defined as follows we'll come back
to what these trained transformations do
in a second I want to focus on that
image folder for now the image folder is
a subset of torches data except objects
it acts just like a list you call length
on it and it gives you the length you
could index it and it spews out a tuple
where the first value is the image and
the next value is a target and in this
case the target zero and zero in this
case represents ants and one represents
bees remembers recall that I had a
transformation thing at the end of that
my image folder definition let's look
let's look at that now so in this case
these are transformations on the images
in the Train folder it's very typical
when you do miss no never works when you
train our network to augment your data
you do some banner flips you change the
colors a little bit and one way to do it
is to use torch visions transformations
to help you do it the the most important
thing here is the normalization we we're
going to normalize our data through this
mean and this is the bottom standard
deviation the reason we do that is to
use a pre trained neural nets in this
case which was trained on image nets so
to use this pre trainer net we have to
normalize our data to the mean and
standard deviation of image nets for the
example we're going to quickly we're
going to train it on a resident model
which is as follows you take in a 3 by
224 3 or visits the colors
you gonna push it through many layers of
functions and at the end it would spit
out a vector of size 2 where zero
represents ants and 1 represents bees to
do this and pi torch it's very simple
you use the torch visions resonate 18
make sure your preaching is true and at
the end you see how I replace the last
funk layer with a linear model
outputting a vector size to notice that
what I named the last layer model that
FC that's one point in the next slide
because when I when you do use a
pre-trained neural network its standard
kind of standard to free its layers as
well so in scorched we have a callback
called freezer and in this case I want
to freeze the layers where the name does
not start with model that FC so this is
everything over here in blue the red one
the red layer is everything you want to
Train okay it's also standard to vary
the learning rate as you turn your train
your no net in this case we could use a
callback called the learning rate
scheduler the LR scheduler in this case
the learning rate starts at Point 1 and
it drops to 10% of its initial value
every seven steps every seven steps what
more could we do in scorch we could do
tech checkpoints we're going to use the
same activity score as we had before
using Val Val accuracy with this is the
same impact scoring we had in the first
example but now we have a new callback
called checkpoints which takes in in
this case two parameters one to specify
the directory we want to save the
checkpoint files in and what to monitor
in this case you see that the name of
our epoch scoring is valid AK in this
case we want them all under there we
want to save the checkpoint when the
validate accuracy is at its best
okay now with all these hot bags we just
stick them all into a list of the
callbacks and this is different since we
already have a validation set predefined
in our folder structure we have to use
this helper method to tell the no net to
not split the training set by itself but
use our own validation data set in this
case so this does it for you
you could call fit and just works notice
that there's a now another column called
CP CP what's a plus over here
means that this accuracy score is the
best value at epoch 8 and what it would
save the state of the model at that
point if you want to look at the folders
what the check points saved you can look
at the directory
remember we call the directory exp
underscore 0 1 so forth it saves 3 files
the history which is a JSON which is
very nice where you could look at the
logs that we had seen before and an
optimizer the premise of the optimizer
and the parameters of your model so tram
stop PT is the parameters of your neural
network at this point in time if you
were in a Jupiter notebook your model
would be a teapot n which is not the
best model that best models at epub 8 -
to load those parameters there's a
function called load params and you pass
in the checkpoint which save the model
epoch 8 and this call predict on it and
they will run through your no nets for
this data for the data in this data set
if this was not in a notebook let's say
a script there's an important point to
make
let's say this is another script you use
change your neural network in a training
script you have another script to do
predictions so this checkpoint is
exactly the same as we saw before this
net object is exactly the same as we had
before but in this case we have to
initialize the nets because when we
define there no nets in the NIP method
these objects the pre train model is not
initialized yet you have to initialize
it first and then you could load the
parameters of your checkpoint into the
model and now you could predict as
before all right
what's more let's say you want to dock
your eyes this thing right you want to
use it with numpy the first thing you
have to make sure is numpy is the
correct shape in this case dreesen
colors in this case i want to run the no
net through one image you represent the
one in the beginning and you call or
predict on it and it would spit out a
number a rate of size two and if you
want to know them the probability you
call softmax okay that's simple next
remember the last item I want to talk
about is the data science Bowl the data
science Bowl was a cow competition this
year which had to do with images of
cells every wants to
generated at ASET consists of three
types of images one where it's kind of
purple one where it's black and one
where it's whitish and the data set
consists of the corresponding masks
along with it you see that this the
wideness could corresponds to the nuclei
of your data set in this case I had to
define my own data set objects which I
call cells data set okay the cells data
set the cells data set is also and lists
like objects where you could index it
like a list and it would spit out a
couple of images and mass so the first
item is the image itself the second item
is the mass this for the model you want
to Train in this example we want to
train a you net class no network in this
case it takes an image of size three
times two eighty eight runs it through a
nonlinear layers and then spit out an
image of one by yeah one by two 88
okay in this case we want to use
transfer learning as well so it'd be
good to free some layers as well so we
could use scorches callback api with the
freezer as well and give it the name of
these four layers which i called
see what I called CoV co and the number
so in this case freezer also supports a
glob in this case is you see it's
clubbed with CoV so this will freeze
everything that begins with CoV when
using a unit classifier it turns out
it's very bad at the borders of your
so in this case it's very bad at doing
classification on these edges on the
edges so one way to work around this is
to use a reflection on the edges of your
image okay so you see how this at the
end there's this reflections of the
inner image so you can span your image
as a whole
next the images do are not all 288 by
288 so another way to do of this is one
way to do this is to use a patch data
set where you drop different patches of
your data to feed into your neural nets
to do this in Python
I created two objects these data set
objects do exactly what just do that
before one common metric to use when you
do image segmentation is the IOU metric
where it's every of the overlap over the
area of the union where if your
prediction and you're over and your true
values overlap exactly then this value
is one if they don't overlap then a zero
right so you want them to have a good
overlap over the Union to define this
metric in Python you could approximate
it at that
I won't go the details of the
approximation it returns the metric in
this case I want to call mix score to
create a scoring object now like you had
like we had before we could define it
each pop scoring objects with that was
scoring the score give it a name in this
case Val Val underscore IOU and set
lower is better is false
also we have a check point in this case
you have another directory name this is
important because the experiment we did
before so what the experiment d4 is
another folder this saves the state of
your model in another directory and in
this case we don't want too modern we
want to monitor the validation loss
validation IOU of this scoring so that
it
IOU and you
the best of it now remember that we
don't want to count the padding of your
image and so we need a custom criteria
for this for this example that knows
about the padding we just did so we want
to ignore the loss at the edges okay so
we have a new validation loss I defined
and it has a parameter called padding
and if you want to adjust this parameter
in our neural net object we could pass
in the parameter with add under the
double underscore notation to set this
padding parameter to 16 as shown here
and also my unit object I just called
units and then the unit of weather that
we had before how many of you have heard
of fat AI okay fascinating I didn't
expect that that's AI thought of it this
neat little burning xscape Euler where
you start from a low learning rate and
jump to really high one and go back down
to a low one this is called a one cycle
policy and you can also implement this
in scores as well using a cyclic
learning rate yeah and you have hyper
parameters such as the base learning
rate and mastering rate except where you
want the learning rate to be so in
summary you have this huge learning no
net object you give it the callback same
as before you define you can define a
batch size you could tell it how many
epochs you want to go over you give it
callbacks and you give it the predefined
split we had P the Transpac because we
have about additions that we want to
focus on I've been ignoring a slight
technical issue details about defining
the thing there's a little bit more
parameters to set because internally
Scorch uses the data loader object in pi
torch which consists of these two
parameters and
then pin memory and the number workers
and I'd like to set these values as such
where this iterator train is the
training is the data loaded object for
the training set and I'd like to set the
shuffle to true and this is the more
important part you wanna I want to set
the number workers before which means we
spawned four processes to process our
images when we do image augmentation
because we want to feed our GPUs
constantly and keep them at 100%
lastly 10 memory is a minor optimization
where we don't have to keep on
allocating memory on the GPU
every time we feed my data into the GPU
we do exactly the same for validation
and now we could call fit and in fit you
get what we expect before now we have a
column called validate valid and the
score I owe you and you see that the
checkpoint checkpoint of the module at
epoch 17 all right what's a plus sign
just like before
we could lower the parameters using the
lower params with the best checkpoints
we could call predict to get our
prediction and these predictions are
values there are any of you values so if
you want to get the probability in this
case and so it's binary you could use
the sigmoid function it would spit out
it would map any of you number to any
number to a number between 0 and 1 so
what does the results look like in this
case looks like so like this where the
first column is the true values of the
mass these the third column is the
images and in the middle this is the
star of the show is the predictions in
this case you can see how well our nona
does and this is interesting to me
because I when I was creating this
tutorial I didn't think this would
happen because there's three different
images and this just handles it very
well so it goes to show the
of deep learning and the image sector so
in closing high torch is a secular
compound known at library we went
through Fitz partial Fitz predict
separates and because it has a branch
you could do the grid search and random
search CVS random searching in using
cyclins rancer random search and grid
search to search a hyper grammars for
your module also since it supports the
fit it's you could use pipelines as well
as we saw in the first example in
chapter way the chain loop notice that
how when we call fit we didn't have to
worry about all the little details we
had in the first three slides we just
call fit and it just works
next we have callbacks you want to epoch
scoring freezer check point our
scheduler there's a few more that I
didn't go over you could even create
your long own I go and do the
documentation and documentation the
documentation that this link there is
tutorials like that were created that
runs on Google am so you could run
through examples in scorch and play
around with the code base i we on the
issue board we've we welcome issues i'm
there pretty much to answer questions if
you have any questions with scorch and
these slides i generated and the data
that the data the module or the code i
used on images are at this github link
so you could reproduce everything I had
in just in these slides if you clone
this we github and follow instructions
to download the data yep 30 minutes yeah
yeah thank you for listening and that's
oh that's appendix I had a lot more
slides and I want to fit it into 35
minutes fast
eh I wanted to use fast AI for a while
but if you look at that a eyes codebase
it's they like to use tiny act they
breathe a a lot of things so it's takes
a little time to understand how the code
works in the path a a library but this
is better now because of the fast AI 1.0
so I think it's good to use both
frameworks in this case we're fast a
gives you the the results right away
whilst course you have to know a little
more details about training neural nets
and if that's the difference between
those two
questions huh what do you know what
algorithms are in those steps and number
two relates to the gentleman's question
back here if you have two different
paradigms that you're going to use where
are the bottlenecks in each and why
would you purses the other or anything
else depending on the bottlenecks
there are have you heard of combinations
yes there convolutions fashion or
meditations and re re o you from the
values L II owe you their vendors so
it's just that's it those those are the
three building blocks of those
combinations you I think I had it's dude
they're all this is this is where it's
flexible you could use whatever you want
almost in these combinations but as long
as I use three by threes and one by one
like stack together but if you read up
on it
people have expanded this unit to
include what everyday one in these
circled blue layers depending on the
problem the hot button this out in this
see train a you net well yeah yeah
it's when you define the no net you go
through the standard standard um the
cats grading stance forward this this
nonlinear manifold and you're trying to
find the lowest loss function in my case
it was the binary loss what what stops
this thing from working well one of the
issues where the guy said was the
reflection type thing but what's the
saving again this thing I haven't yeah I
haven't found a be a good one yeah
answer it's a bun answer is this mascot
meter well but there are some questions
where it doesn't work where you walk so
it's it worked really well for binary
mass since its specifically
oh so at the end of the slides where I
did I just skipped because I'm this this
is there's new features such as here
this feature I didn't talk about which
is a train and checkpoint which was
saved the no net at the end of training
so that you could do continued training
in scripts so it automatically loads
your checkpoint every time you run the
script so let's say the first run you
run through one to ten you run the
script again it goes from eleven to
twenty and so four and so on one thing I
want to implement now is a control see I
type object where we exit when it exits
it just saves the model for you so you
could save your work Wow if your
computer goes down for instance so
that's something I'm pushing for
yeah whatever ports towards supports
that supports as well because those
convolutions are in the module thing so
if however you want to define your
module and pie chart you could define
here as well oh and you know how a
module uses name parameters to so with
those layers or names they have a name
if you unfreeze there's also a
corresponding unfreeze ur callback that
unfreezes things however you want you
could you could even three unfreeze and
freeze things depending on yuck so
there's a lot of things you could do
with the API data and go through so you
could freeze and unfreeze things that
well it should because we have to push
we have to put that version into the CI
and you know contains delivery and
whatnot to make sure it works but we
haven't done that just yet we would we
will get on that
No
I'm kind of a new
and we're interested we have high volume
we're just getting started
do you need it how fast you need the
image the object segmentation that's
video video
how many trucks so you could use this
framework with video with even text
video to the series images so one if
you've needed in real time the object
segmentation of your time the first
thing I would do would be to use
traditional because you're just counting
trucks so you could use open CV and you
use traditional County Memphis to do it
but one of the first known that I would
want to use would be called the yellow
no network which does object object
segmentation really quickly and into the
bounding boxes and it works really well
with video alright so if you need it
real time I would just go straight
through this algorithm called Yolo v3
you could Google that and you could use
it with scores as well yeah
over time
[Applause]